for more than four days we've seen the
flooded streets of houston neighborhood
by neighborhood well this morning we're
getting a wider view of the devastation
improved conditions have cleared the way
for non-rescue helicopters to fly over
some areas andrika duncan took to the
sky yesterday for a big picture view of
what houston faces jerika good morning
good morning these rescue helicopters
have been in this neighborhood which is
surrounded by three bayous these
helicopters have had a rough one the
last few days when you consider the fact
that they've been flying through
torrential rains and high winds all to
bring people who are stranded to safety
and now that the weather has cleared a
bit we were able to see what houston
looks like from up above
even as the waters finally start to
recede the scope of houston's flooding
and its aftermath is devastating so how
far are we up in the air right now right
now we're at 700 feet above the ground
as a civilian aircraft we were not
allowed to fly over some of the worst
hit neighborhoods but we still saw
street after street filled with water
and as dusk fell the eerie sight of
businesses with their lights on looking
like islands in a parking lot lake
helicopter pilot michael hume flew
through storm conditions to get to south
texas on monday
were you scared i mean i know you have a
lot of experience but that's a lot
there's a lot going on uh this kind of
weather patterns that were going on was
probably some of the craziest i've seen
in terms of the ferociousness of the
storms how quickly they were coming
around
it's that kind of ferociousness that
rescue helicopters have been facing all
week flying in lower more dangerous
conditions
not all heroes wear capes and a lot more
flight suits from the air tuesday night
we could see conditions are improving
i'm just thankful that you're actually
able to see the sun set because that
sun's going to bring a ray of hope to
the houston area
something that this city without a doubt
could use now as we were in the air
there were about nine rescue helicopters
in our vicinity nora still working to
help those in need
yeah there's still a rescue operation
going on here indeed jericho thank you
so much